you left
cte after fred right it was around
so freddie got there and um
what was that the beginning of 2010 i
left and
now he got there beginning at 2000 and
le yeah 2010. it was like 2010 2011 this
year
and i left like in the public i left in
like 12 but i was already gone from
a little money situation like the end of
2011.
you know i mean yeah it's crazy because
obviously
um you and fred have kept a relationship
for so long despite a situation like
that might
you know people kind of choose up you
know what i'm saying no they chose up on
me
and that's the only reason why i [ __ ]
with freddie so tough because he was the
only [ __ ] that stayed
down with me like in my even when i met
you that time only reason i went on that
tour
because i had he knew that i i was
leaving the ct situation they [ __ ] me
over like 400 000.
so i'm like man [ __ ] these [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying and i have a big
enough microphone to go and just be
dissing because it's going to make me
look better so i'm like man i'ma just do
what i'm going to do
you know what i'm saying and um and
everybody like bailed on me
and i had so much slander i was going
through much so much [ __ ] at the time
you know um that everybody bailed on me
he was the only one that was like bro
still he like that's how i came to
arizona he like bro you got to get out
of that last yeah
it's [ __ ] you got a lot of [ __ ] going
on right now come on tour with me
and i remember that i'm like bro bring
my gun and all that [ __ ] like nah
i ain't telling you don't bring it but
right right you ain't gonna need it
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ] for
a rap concert like shoot me
you feel me ain't gonna need no pistol
or not no protection you're like nah
it's not like that
yeah it's crazy because i know fred's
side of what happened
at uh at cte um and it seems as if
a lot of the people almost everyone who
was around gz early on is not there
anymore nobody [ __ ] with that [ __ ] and
no and nobody's got anything good to say
about
and i've met jeezy a bunch but you know
even like uh
shout out to car you know carbon 15 15
is you know that's that was my guy who
was
you know anytime i needed anything jeezy
related i would hit 15. you know what
i'm saying
and obviously about the 15 we still be
great business real dude man he's still
i still talk everybody over there damn
near
like puller just got out i spoke to him
um briefly
um but like me freddie i talked to king
all the time what do you think um i mean
you were around jeezy
a lot longer than fred so you know you
were around that whole situation yeah
he was like man why ain't tell me i'm
like bro what i look like i can't tell i
didn't bring you in the situation i
would have been like
you feel me this ain't it bro this ain't
gonna happen you knew it wasn't it
pretty soon pretty quick or i knew it
wasn't it
when he when they appeared on the bus
and i'm like what are you doing here bro
he's like man
i'm from the sign over here and i'm like
oh we're going to see i double a
and um they like you know him i'm like
yeah that's just the homie what you mean
hey like he from gary i'm like this
[ __ ] living in l.a bro like we
got songs together and everything so
they're like okay cool i would never mad
at freddy i'm looking at jeezy like
[ __ ] you bringing new artists in and
you can't even you can't even work the
articles you've had on your label for
god yeah
[ __ ] in debt and some most [ __ ] we
don't have no music like what what's
going on
you know what i'm saying and so
i ain't gonna i think i think one day he
was just like um
the way i left was he caught this big
old meeting and [ __ ] was like yeah i'm
not giving no money out which
was giving no money out in the first
place and he like uh
you know [ __ ] gotta gotta go out and
use the name and the label to get money
so i'm like that's what i did you know
what i mean and i went and got a
four hundred thousand dollar deal for
some music half the music that was
already out
and half was unreleased music and the
[ __ ] sent me assistant deceased
i was with smc so he told you i
think he told me to go do this and then
he went to do it
he hit you with the season decisions
[ __ ] your papers [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] up
and i'm getting your artist money
i could have just pocketed all of this
[ __ ] myself i've been like [ __ ] y'all
you know i mean and and from that point
on i'm like brother
they had me fool like this family first
and then some real family [ __ ] i was
gonna say like based on your
you were around jeezy i guess probably
when he was transitioning out of
being uh known as like a really hardcore
gangster rapper into him kind of
becoming more of a staple in him i was
there for
so i met him today um
the day thug motivation went gold in
vegas
wow i mean and then i was with them damn
near
all-time great album yeah i go knock
that yeah that was a great album
all the way up until what the 103
or some [ __ ] like that